okay each other yeah in your opinion MSA
oblong what has been these yet this
year's Peace Prize Loris most important
and most significant contribution to
peace
both of them have raised awareness of
one of the most important things in
today's world they need to give young
people hope
let them go to school and after that get
a job rather than to be involved in
extremist activities you had some 278
candidates nominates to choose among was
it the difficult process towards the end
to when you gave this announcement today
it is always difficult work that's why
we have this small committee that is
sitting together in so many meetings
coping through all the candidates using
experts from Norway from abroad and at
the end of the day we have worked us
together conclusion Malala is a young
woman and some people say that giving
Nobel Peace Prize to such a young woman
would be like making her an even bigger
target for extremist groups are you
afraid of that
well we have thought about it of course
but we have seen that she has received
many other prizes and she had she has
appeared in a very solid manner she is
very convincing she has a very good
agenda and if we cannot give a prize to
a young person how can it be what kind
of signal is that that we need the young
people more than ever 60% of the of the
population in poor countries are young
people what signal do you think that the
price to Malala will give to the Muslim
world that
Islam is not about extremism it is about
human beings their rights there as well
girls as well as boys women and men they
have the same rights I think that as all
other world religions this is a also
important part of Islam and not what we
are witnessing today using misusing
Islam for extremist purposes let me
quote from your announcement today the
Nobel Committee regards it as an
important point for a Hindu and the
Muslim an Indian and Pakistani to join
any common struggle for education and
against extremism is this just as much a
piece for stimulating an ongoing process
yes we with this price we give an
important signal that regardless so
which religion you belong to you can
fight for the same for a common course
and it is also very important to say
that the big religions we have in the
broader day they are peaceful and they
have the same goals the same human basis
for human beings is this a humanitarian
peace primarily or a human right price
price I would say both right to
education is of course is not one of the
but could say the the basic
rights like freedom of expression
freedom of assembly but of course it's a
social right she becomes more and more
important in today's world and this must
be a great ceremony on December the 10th
I think so it will be so I'm so much
looking forward to this bringing these
two outstanding people together coming
from Pakistan and India well I'm I'm
very but internationally will this
decision party committee be regarded as
a non controversial decision in some
circles yes but it is it will be quite
controversial
many places think about also my own
country how people like to buy cheap
goods very often produced by children so
we have also - we have to sing to send a
signal to our own people here in Norway
in Sweden and in which part of the world
since the first Nobel Peace Prize was
boarded in 1900 and gone you have the
committee have has given prices to
pioneer zone of peace movements to top
politicians to people fighting for arms
control and disarmament and to person
fighting for human rights
how will your historically discard this
year's price I think this is in the
tradition of people fighting for human
rights and humanitarian crises we are
always coming back to this track and the
two other tracks which is about the
determined arms control what Alfred
Nobel called convening peace Congress is
named a two
to praise those organizations everybody
that are constituting
the world in an organized way
is it possible to to regard this year's
price or this year's Peace Prize
laureates if you want to compare them to
Prairie as the winners of the Peace
Prize it's it possible well I think it's
a little bit difficult but it is in the
tradition of humanitarian action work
human rights and in accordance with
their alfred nobel's well absolutely
what can contribute more to the
fraternity between nations then to
people to people coming from India and
Pakistan where we have had conflicts for
how many decades and coming from two
religions working together for the same
course
how can one contribute more to
fraternity between nations thank you mr.
Yulin and good luck for December the
10th thank you